[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
allgemeiner zuschauer haben sich einen
veganen kuchen von mir gewünscht und da
habe ich gedacht machen wir doch einen
veganen schokokuchen und obwohl der
kuren veganes also keine eier und keine
milchprodukte enthalten sind und
allgemein keine tierischen produkte ist
es wirklich ein super saftiger kuchen
und ich werde später dem rad beim
probieren einfach nicht verraten das
vegan ist und dann darf er diesen neuen
showchor einmal testen und dann bin ich
sehr auf sein urteil gespannt reduziert
die schoko version ihr könnt natürlich
dieses rezept auch ganz einfach
abwandeln und auch einen hellen kuchen
machen
ihr könnt noch kirschen mit rein geben
oder andere früchte nüsse passen auch
wunderbar dazu also seht dieses rezept
als grundrezept und dann könnt ihr ganz
viele abwandlungen machen ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten die ich benutzt habe für
den kuchen brauche ich 150 km 50 gramm
kakaopulver 200 gramm zucker etwas
vanille extrakt jeweils einen halben
teelöffel natron backpulver und salz 100
milliliter mineralwasser 100 milliliter
orangensaft 50 milliliter sonnenblumenöl
einen esslöffel essig und 50 gramm
apfelmus
die zubereitung ist ganz einfach ihr
nehmt jetzt die trockenen zutaten und
gibt sie in einer schüssel beim
kakaopulver könnt ihr auch gerne ein
bisschen weniger nehmen so schmeckt halt
richtig schokolade zucker backpulver
natron und salz und die zutaten werden
jetzt schon mal gut verrührt
jetzt kommen die flüssigen zutaten dazu
natürlich ein bisschen vanille extrakt
für den geschmack dann das mineralwasser
das macht das alles ein bisschen
lockerer orangensaft wegen das säure
wegen dem natron natron braucht um auf
geht immer ein bisschen säure dann das
öl noch mal bisschen es sich wegen der
säure und apfelmus apfelmus dient oft
als ersatz also das könnt ihr wirklich
immer ganz gut als ersatz nehmen egal in
welchem teil jetzt alles gut verrühren
und dann haben wir den teig schon fertig
wer möchte könnte hier zum beispiel noch
nüsse zufügen kokosraspeln oder auch ein
bisschen gewürze wie zimt zum beispiel
oder auch tonkabohne ich lasse es jetzt
so das wird ein ganz normaler
schokokuchen jetzt nämlich eine backform
ihr könnt auch eine springform nehmen
oder einen runden back ring zum beispiel
ich wollte jetzt einfach eine schöne
backform das ist jetzt der eine teil von
meiner überraschungs backform da habe
ich so ein süßes herbst auf der
unterseite und die bespricht mit dem bug
trend space ist auch vegan und dann mit
dem mehl ausstreuen aber ihr könnt aus
dem teig zum beispiel auch muffins
herstellen das geht auch ganz gut
[Musik]
jetzt kann der teig schon gebacken
werden
[Musik]
jetzt ist der kuchen fertig gebacken und
nach dem backen habe ich ihn kurz
abkühlen lassen und dann direkt auf
einem kuchengitter gestürzt damit er
schön abkühlen kann
ihr könnt ihn jetzt gerne so lassen oder
auch mit etwas puderzucker oder süßem
schnee bestreuen
oder so wie ich noch einen guss machen
ich mache jetzt einen auch veganen
schokoladenguss natürlich dafür nehme
ich jetzt 100 gramm puderzucker 40 kam
cacau etwa wenn euch das ein bisschen zu
viel ist können auch bislang weniger
nehmen und an flüssigkeit nimmt jetzt
entweder wasser oder einen saft zum
beispiel oder auch soja mais hafer
mensch ich nehme zu espresso weil wir
das gerne essen und gerne trinken und
jetzt kann ich alles schön verrühren
[Musik]
und damit kann ich den kuchen jetzt
bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt kann angeschnitten werden
leider habe ich mich mit der zeit
verschätzt ich bin schon ein bisschen
früher fertig daher ist bei murat noch
nicht zurück heute und deswegen darf ich
mir also richten zusammen schon mal
richtig lecker und jetzt die
geschmacksprobe
da ist super leicht also schmeckt echt
super er ist auch nicht zu süß den
espresso schmeckt man auch eigentlich
gar nicht raus und er ist einfach
wunderbar schokoladig und echt gut also
dass ich den halben teelöffel salz drin
habe das gleich die süße total gut aus
und er schmeckt echt super lecker also
zusätzlich später dem rad mal vor wie
immer gespannt was er dazu sagt und ich
glaube es amira darf später auch noch
ein stückchen probieren und die l und
wenn ihr den kuchen auch mal nachmachen
möchte egal ob vegan oder nicht vegan
dann probiert ihn einfach mal aus das
rezept steht auf meinem blog auf sex -
blog.de ich wünsche euch viel spaß dabei
derzeit geht es super einfach und ganz
ganz schnell und mit nur wenigen zutaten
also bis zum nächsten mal war gut
[Musik]